hey this next story is just unbelievable
I've talked to you about the tension
between Donald Trump and his chief of
staff John Kelly before I don't agree
with Kelly's politics but you can't
really deny that he is sort of at least
compared to Trump more of a no-nonsense
type of guy and we saw very shortly
after John Kelly became chief of staff
replacing who was it rinse Priebus right
yeah that the you saw the sort of
pushing out from the inner circle of the
more extreme folks like Steven Bannon
and the whacky Anthony scaramouche's
from Trump's inner circle now that
doesn't necessarily mean that they lost
influence but at least publicly Kelly
Cohen Kelly coming in coincided with
them being pushed out of being so
publicly and visibly close to Donald
Trump there's a really interesting new
report from New York Times
magda New York Magazine rather written
by Olivia newton-john 'old Trump has
actually tried to fire chief of staff
John Kelly several times but that John
Kelly ignores it and that Trump is sort
of like unsure how to fire John Kelly he
usually calls John Kelly to fire other
people and he I just imagined Trump
sitting at the White House looking at
his phone going who can I call to fire
Kelly because I can't I can't have
Melania do it doesn't seem Kushner's got
the I don't know how to fire the guy
that's what it seems is going on here
this is just the best a White House
official spoke to Olivia Newton ooh York
Magazine piece on the condition of
anonymity and said to her and is quoted
in the article as saying when the
president says I need you to leave Kelly
just ignores him I think the president
just doesn't know who to call to fire
him normally if the president wanted to
fire somebody he would call Kelly to do
it but there's nobody else to call this
is extraordinary I actually don't know
whether to say it's hilarious or the
stuff of nightmares because it indicates
a level of dysfunction and incompetence
that we definitely suspected but maybe
didn't realize was actually
that this this bad and this egregious
but it all fits with what else has been
reported right it's been reported
previously that John Kelly thinks Trump
is an idiot has referred to him as an
idiot in private has referred to him as
unhinged in private it's been record
reported by Politico that while John
Kelly is still chief of staff in name
like he's formerly still the chief of
staff but he's no longer really chief of
staff because Trump has stopped taking
advice from him and it's been reported
multiple times that Kelly might be on
his way out so the story's coherent with
the broader narrative that we're aware
of
but Trump being unsure of how to get rid
of this guy and Kelly ignoring Trump's
attempts to fire him is another level of
incompetence altogether I would have
liked to see Trump take the Jeff
Sessions approach on this which is not
to directly try to fire him but just to
go on a bunch of like cable news shows
and make it known that he wants this guy
out yeah call him beleaguered and the
rest of it now it didn't work with
sessions but it actually has worked with
others and this is this is the funny so
part of this I can't tell if it's scary
or funny the one definitely funny part
is why can't Trump just sit Kelly down
privately and just say listen we're
letting you go I'm serious I need you
out today I've notified Secret Service
and you're gonna be out today isn't
Trump supposedly the Alpha who's known
for telling people that their fires like
on his old reality show that's what he
would do he would tell people you're
you're just out you're fired and they
would go and it's also funny that for
that same reason on some level Trump is
a coward right Trump is a coward a ton
of the people fired by Trump as you
mentioned Pat it didn't work with
sessions but they learned about it
through the media Rex Tillerson I
believe found out via Twitter that he
was going to be let go Trump didn't call
him and say we're letting you go
James Comey as FBI a former FBI agent
Josh Campbell has told the story James
Comey found out when he was speaking to
I don't know if it was FBI or see he was
been giving a speech somewhere and there
was like a TV tuned to Fox News in the
back of the room and that's how James
Comey found out that he had been fired
so this actually is a pattern Trump
usually will leak to the media
or tweet or something like that as
opposed to just sitting down and saying
we're letting you go
maybe it's because Trump has so much
admiration for these military types oh
yeah John Kelly definitely fits that
description huger's Trump always talks
about how great Mad Dog Madison for
example and even after firing Michael
Flynn he expressed some regret about
that like yeah we can we can invite him
back into the administration under a
different title I would like to see him
just take responsibility put on the big
boy pants and do it like an adult who
manages people and is in charge of
hiring and firing just do it as opposed
to this pathetic nonsense
send me your thoughts I want to hear
from you about this I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman follow me and follow the show on
twitter at david pakman show got a great
one for you including part two of my
interview with Nathan J Robinson about
the intellectual dark web it's coming up
a little bit later on today's show was
made possible in part by scion games and
their new game for phone and tablet
called antidote which is an award
winning strategy game it's all about
using vaccines to defend the human body
from bacteria and viruses it's fast
paced the graphics are amazing the game
has actually been commended by the World
Health Organization because it has a
mission to fight back against anti
vaccine misinformation so the game is
educational and fun to play download
antidote for free on your phone or
tablet in the Google Play Store or the
iOS App Store and have a blast using
vaccines and the body's immune system to
fight off deadly diseases and don't
forget to search for scion games on
Twitter Facebook and Instagram if you're
watching this on youtube I've put the
links under the video